okay but up next how to arrange the food
in your fridge so you can trim your
waistline and save some money stay with
us welcome back want to clean up your
diet but not sure where to start well
how about with your fridge registered
dietitian Abby sharp shows us how
arranging food just right can help save
you time calories and money Abby
Goodnough thank you yeah in the morning
this is always my goal to make things
ahead like on Sunday a portion it out
and get it ready absolutely yeah like a
quick little fridge makeover is a great
way to kick start your healthy eating
habits before summer I think and I've
got some really great tips for you to
get started so first of all don't waste
healthy food I think that sounds obvious
but I know a lot of us have good
intentions when we buy lots of great
fresh produce but a lot of the times we
just end up throwing out because it's
gone bad before we get to use right so
there are some rules of thumb about how
to store your produce to help it last
longer so first of all we'll start with
fruit so most fruit are ethylene
producing and ethylene is a gas that
helps our fruit ripen faster okay so
what I like to do with fruit that
continues to ripen after its being
picked like peaches for example as I set
it on the counter until it reaches its
optimum ripeness however we want to
define that because some people like
this often sundered like ready okay and
then I put them in the crisper drawer in
the fridge and the first doesn't
necessarily stop the the uh clean gas
production but it does help slow it down
I was going to ask you that because I'll
be honest I opened up my fridge Sunday
night and there was some stuff producing
a lot of ethylene yes here's another
really quick tip too because a lot of
people don't know that you can actually
change this this is great on the
frigidaire fridge because we have a
little vegetable or fruit it changes the
humidity level so you want to put it on
a low humidity for your fruit and that
what that does is it opens up a little
window lets the ethylene gas out a
little bit so it doesn't become like an
ethylene hot box in there and cause it
to rot now on the flip side we've got
vegetables so most vegetables are
ethylene sensitive so we want to give
them as far away from the fruit as
possible so that we you know it's not
kind of getting in contact with that
ethylene gas so what
I like to do to protect my spinach or
Mike Greene's pop it into one of these
glad storage bags which really locks in
the freshness with a little piece of
paper towel just to absorb any excess
moisture okay and this is going to go in
the other crisper drawer so segregation
is important here and this when I put on
a high community and what that means is
it's going to allow my vegetables to
stay nice and crisp but at the same time
it shuts that little window so the
ethylene gas is coming out of my fruit
drawer doesn't get into does that very
good you know I'm so surprised it
actually has a function because I've
seen that in so averages whether it's
frigid air or any other fridge in it
just that okay you don't you ignored it
yeah now you know what it's there for
perfect so now of course our fruit and
veggies are lasting a little bit longer
now you actually have to use them so my
next tip is to do a little bit of prep
work ahead so i always find most
families are crazy busy in the morning
so breakfast tends to be the meal that
we we go and grab a pastry or something
so it always do my breakfast ahead of
time so what I've done here is I set up
my little little glad containers with
some Greek yogurt in the bottom and
frozen berries on top and the reason I
use frozen even though I know we're
coming into fruit season is because by
the time I get it to work to eat it's
fought out but it's cut my yogurt nice
and cool so beauty right there all right
and then I got some little snack baggies
of some almonds I can throw that on top
it's a perfect little meal also batch
cooking is really great so on the
weekend when you have some time I do
like a big batch of quinoa and I could
just throw it into stir fries or
whatever it is I'm making how long is
this gonna last probably about three
days over there four days especially you
know you keep it in in a sealed
container in the fridge um chicken also
what I like to do is I'll grill like
three or four pounds slice it up pop it
into freezer bags and then just pull the
freezer bags out throughout the week pop
it in a salad and a soup throw it in
your stir-fry you've already got that
all taken care of very smart how long
will those eggs last so I think just a
few you know couple days I always have
like a couple a couple in the day and if
I have a family you know you can you can
divvy them up so a few days for sure yes
fresh or hard boy those are hard-boiled
oh yeah in only a couple of days um
maybe
four or five okay I got to make note of
that yeah so um the other kind of tip I
wanted to mention is to trick yourself
into eating healthy and this is this is
funny because when we open the fridge we
tend to describe the first thing that we
see right so we're really in a hangar II
state so use that to your advantage so
one thing I did I've got cupcakes in
there but I've hidden them I can't see
them so out of sight out of mind yep
right and then of course all my healthy
food is right in front of my face so
I've got my hummus got little baggies of
carrots I've got my fairies in a clear
container that's really important
because we tend to you know it's a lot
of work to have to look inside
apparently look inside a bowl or shows
that clear container because you see
what you've got right in front of your
eyes so that's really important to ya
one thing I started doing a while back
was just buy healthy food in that way
that's my only choice right now if you
do want to have something that's a treat
or that I'll go whether that's a really
good option too I know but it's hard for
families with kids and you know to mean
there's always something lying around
that's tempting absolutely dietitian
Abby sharp thank you so much thank you
nice to see you alright next on the
morning show the hottest toys for summer
will get a preview coming up after this
quick break stay with